in this video I want to talk about how
transcription in eukaryotes get started
like it started via this process called
chromatin remodeling and the reason why
is because DNA new carry-outs
is wrapped around proteins called
histones now these histones they carry a
certain charge what charge do they carry
well if they're interacting with DNA
it'd be helpful to know what DNA's
charge is DNA has a sugar phosphate
backbone and because of that it has a
negative charge the negative charge of
DNA is due to the phosphate groups in
the backbone so if DNA has a negative
charge what would you expect the
histones to have they would carry a
positive charge because if they're
interacting opposite charges attract it
would make sense that the histones would
carry positive charges now these
histones are proteins and proteins are
made up of long chains of amino acids so
these positive charges are coming from
some sort of amino acid the the amino
acids that have positive charges are the
basic ones histidine arginine and lysine
now these histones are rich at least
their surface is rich in lysine residues
so lysine and so they have positive
charges on their surface where they
interact with DNA so in order for
transcription to occur we can't have
these histones in the way this DNA needs
to be free so that the RNA polymerase
and any transcription factors can go in
find a promoter region bind to it and
start transcribing so we need to get rid
of these histones in order to get
transcription to go so if we initially
have a histone with some lysine residues
on it those have positive charges so if
we can get rid of this positive charge
then maybe you would be able to free up
the DNA and there's actually an enzyme
that does that it's called histone
acetyl transferase otherwise known as
and what it does is it adds an acetyl
group to that lysine getting rid of that
positive charge now se does look like
this and you ever call a pseudo Co a it
would look like this would have a methyl
in this carbon eel group here and then a
co a so if we just kill that Co a
portion off this part there's an acetyl
group so here what we've done is we've
taken if the histones from having
positive charges to neutral charges
would put that in blue to neutral
charges so now the histones the histone
infinity for the DNA has decreased
because of that DNA is unpackaged and
when it's unpackaged DNA is ready for
transcription so that is how you carry
odds prepare for transcription now what
if you want to repackage that DNA you
have to be able to go backwards and that
brought about repackaging DNA if you
want to go backwards let's put this in
purple no moon up let's do this color
going back this way there are enzymes
called histone deacetylases oops acetyl
laces or HD a C's so what they do is
they do you see the lace the histones I
get rid of that acetyl group and get the
get the positive charge back onto lysine
so that you can have the DNA reassociate
with those histones hope that video was
helpful I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at move University at
gmail.com and see the description below
for more details
thank you for watching